welcome to a new video everyone today is
going to be a look at little nightmare
2's ending and what it means
today's video is going to be split into
a few parts first is the recap of little
nightmares 1.
it's been a couple years since its
release so for those who need a
refresher make sure to watch that part
the next section is going to be
everything we do in little nightmares 2
up until the ending no theory crafting
just descriptive commentary on our
journey and the last portion of the
video will cover the regular ending
secret ending and some theories as to
what is going on in the universe
with all that out of the way let's get
started with the recap of little
nightmares one
for the little nightmares recap we play
as a kid named six in the main game and
someone only known as the kid in the dlc
we are inside a structure called the mob
which is an ocean liner where the kids
of the game are housed both of our
protagonist's goals are to escape the
maw when we first play a six we end up
getting a strange dream of a lady
wearing a mask as six we make our way
through the prison section of the maw
and start to become
hungry thankfully we are helped by
someone in the cafe but this hunger
detail is quite relevant throughout the
rest of the game
after the prison we make it to the lair
where we meet the janitor quite
frequently
six becomes hungry again but luckily she
finds more food but as we discover it
was a trap place by the janitor
back to the kid he also gets a strange
dream but of a hand coming from the
water and grabbing him
this stream then becomes a reality as we
make our way through some familiar areas
into a hole that takes us into the
sewage system of the maw where we could
see the creature in the water the kid
manages to escape the creature in the
water but is also caught by the janitor
shortly after and now we can see both
our protagonists together going back to
six momentarily she breaks out of her
cage while the janitor drags the kid
away
she navigates the layer while
simultaneously avoiding the janitor
until the final section where six cuts
off his arms with the door
she makes her way to the kitchen where
the twin chefs are located we can see
them using the kids ingredients in some
way as if six is caught she is then
dumped into the pot
kids don't seem to be the only item on
the menu however as loads of various
food groups are seen throughout the
kitchen
using the environment 6 escapes the
kitchen and into the guest area we then
see the lady from six's dream in this
area taking a look from up top which
implies she holds some sort of status
and we can of course heavily assume that
this is her ship
we can also see why there is tons of
food in the kitchen as there's a lot of
overweight guests that come in entering
the mall and will eat anything they see
even going as far as chasing us down a
hallway even though there's loads of
food behind them
seems to me that kids are a top quality
meal back to the kid he makes his escape
by ripping through the meat bag he was
put in and ends up in the furnace area
of the maw he befriends tons of gnomes
in this area all of whom help him escape
by using the coal lift this must have
happened before six dealt with the
janitor as his arms are still on his
body during the dlc
the kid makes it to the top of an
elevator and a pan out shot reveals that
the lady is underneath us the kid is now
in the ladies quarters and he needs to
escape
quickly before he's seen which he does
very well using the statue puzzle
and here we can also encounter ghost
kids that will die if we shine a light
at them long enough
inside we meet the lady without her mask
who is spooked by seeing us
in screams we now have to leave and
escape once again but this doesn't work
as we're caught by the lady and turned
into a gnome so now we know that the
gnomes are kids who got the same fate as
us
we end the dlc running around in the
guest area next to a couple of other
gnomes until six arrives however and
it's not shown on screen in the dlc but
it is heavily implied this is the gnome
that six eats in the guest area it's
still not 100 clear why she chose the
gnome and not the sausage but some have
said it could be her downward spiral
into madness as we can see a shadow
version of her in the background
numerous times
regardless six eats the gnome and
continues on after billy escaping
multiple encounters with the guests she
also ends up in the ladies quarters but
six ends up defeating her by using her
mirror against her
six for the last time in the game
becomes hungry once again but the only
thing near her is the lady so she bites
into lily's neck and not only kills her
but gets her powers
as well with supernatural powers at her
disposal six doesn't bother hiding
anymore and walks straight through the
crowd killing everyone and
ultimately escaping the maw ending
little nightmares one
in little nightmares 2 we play as mono
just like in the previous entry in the
series we get a dream sequence of a long
hallway with a door
on the door is a familiar eye we've seen
in little nightmares one countless times
or shot through the tv and awake in a
forest
as we navigate the wilderness we find a
house in the distance as we explore we
find a locked door that once open
reveals a girl in the middle of the room
this is sixth the protagonist of the
last game she's hesitant to ask for her
help but after showing her that we only
want to assist her she joins us for the
rest of the game
from the marks on the wall it's assumed
that she was here a little over a month
as we explore the house we see taxidermy
people the person responsible for this
is the hunter he seems to have a strong
interest in collecting trophies for his
house whether it's animal or
human it's unclear why he's attacking
people and not just animals but it may
have something to do with the pale city
he seems to be both aggressive but
patient as he is aggressive with his
procedures but patient in his hunting in
the little nightmares comics we know
that sixx was captured by the hunter
which explains why she ended up in his
house and maybe explains why she is
still alive as the hunter maybe didn't
want to kill her just yet the hunter
most likely wanted her to die from
natural causes like hunger or
dehydration
if he were to shoot her that would put
holes in her body and probably [ __ ] up
his trophy collection when the body dies
of things like starvation or dehydration
the body is dead but is still
intact unlike being shot where there's
holes in deformations
this can be further reinforced by the
state the other victims in the house are
in minus the faces everything seems to
be quite normal looking after running
and being backed into a corner six and
mano work together to pull the trigger
on a nearby gun and killing the hunter
they then use a door as a raft to make
their way to the pale city
alongside the pale city we see clothes
everywhere but no people we also see an
abundance of tvs it's here where we
discover mono secret power the ability
to
tune into tvs by touching the tv he can
hop into it and see
what's on the other side on that other
side is the hallway from our dream but
we only get so far before six pulls us
out
we then make it to the school where our
obstacles are the bullies and the
teacher
we get introduced to the bullies when
they ambush us in kidnap six the teacher
is a
long-necked individual who is extremely
hard to outrun the bullies seem to
attack us on sight no matter what but
when no one is around they'll just hit
each other as seen by this scene in game
when the teacher is around however they
are very obedient and won't harm one
another by cracking
open their heads with pipes and hammers
we discover that they are porcelain
dolls it's
unclear why they are like this though
were they created by the teacher so she
could be a normal teacher once again
are these all manifestations of past
dead kids who really knows we also see
one of the kids drawing eyes and chalk
which is the same eyes we see throughout
both games
near the end we see six get some revenge
on some of the kids and strangle one to
death before we even get a chance to hit
it
unlike the hunter we don't kill the
teacher we just leave the school and
escape we make
it outside once more and we get to see
six finding her signature yellow
raincoat it's unclear if this one is a
new raincoat or the same one that she
had from the first game but we'll
discuss that in the theory section for
the third chapter we enter the hospital
which has tons of mannequins
mono once again touches the tv and is
pulled out again the hospital has some
tricky puzzles and some more combat but
this time it's hands of mannequins as
well as moving bodies that won't move if
there's a light shining on them after
some long encounters with the mannequins
we meet the doctor who right before
meeting him on a wall has
faces of what could be the residents of
the city some of the faces also look
similar to the faces of the guests and
the maw from little nightmares one
from various descriptions of the
patients and the doctor we can infer
that the patients were once people who
came to the doctor for medical
procedures it's unclear the specific
motives of each patient
as they could have been for legitimate
medical reasons or perhaps more cosmetic
reasons regardless they came to the
doctor looking for aid and he crafted
many organic and inorganic parts onto
these people with the aftermath being
what we see in game
it's also quite possible that he created
the kids that are in the school as
they're made entirely out of inorganic
parts
we can see the doctor working tirelessly
on his creations as he constantly moves
back and forth between multiple patients
and it's also very clear that he cares
for these patients as when we try to
disconnect one of the patient's life
supports he rushes over
immediately to fix them when we try to
escape we are found by the doctor and
are led on a long chase which ends at us
trapping and incinerating him
the fourth chapter is back outside once
more where we see bodies falling from
buildings nearby
we discover this is for the broadcast on
the tvs all the residents are constantly
watching the tv
never taking their eyes off of it and if
it goes out they'll try anything to get
it back
this broadcast is from the giant black
tower in the distance towering over the
city
in some rooms later in the chapter we
can see some pictures of the thin men
with some eyes around him
these exact drawings are everywhere in
the hospital and especially the school
we hop into the tv for the third time
and actually open the door
only to find the thin men instead of the
tv going out he appears on screen this
time and
enters our realm chasing us down the
hallway as we run away we hide under the
bed and six hides under the table except
she is caught and taken by the thin men
our new objective now is to get her back
we can see a glitched version of her
in the room which now explains the
glitch kids we see throughout the game
these are kids who were captured by the
thin man just like six was we also get
to see a glimpse of what's called the
squirming abyss when we enter the tv
again mono now hones in on his skills
with tv
travel and ends up finding a remote to
help him travel through tv dimensions
easier it's here where we can see the
true extent of the broadcast the
residents going as far as falling off
buildings in hopes they can see the
broadcast again
and when their life has drained from
their body due to intensive exposure to
the broadcast they collapse and fall
where they stand
the broadcast has screwed with their
facial features as well twisting their
faces making them unrecognizable while
simultaneously giving them the ability
to
suck us up the same way the thin man did
six we see even more residents crowding
around each other doing nothing but
watching the broadcast they won't even
care that we are inches from them
it's here that the residents eventually
will discover us and chase us throughout
the nearby stores
after hopping through another tv we
enter a room where six is located we
attempt to pull her out but we fail as
the thin man pulls her right back
he finds us once again and chases us for
a very long time
until we can meet him again on different
terms mano takes off his hat and uses
his powers to destroy the thin man
his powers are strong enough to shake
the nearby buildings and give him the
option of teleporting large distances
like the thin men
we then enter the giant tower which
starts chapter 5. right at the beginning
we uncovered that the hallway we've seen
in the tvs this whole time was the main
entrance to the black tower as
mono we ascend the tower in hopes of
finding six which we do by following the
noises of the music box we do end up
finding the source of the music box but
also finding a huge distorted version of
six as well to break her out of this
form and for us to escape we need to
break that music box
she's extremely defensive of it and will
even kill us if we get too close to her
in this room however though is a
suitcase
which is oddly familiar to the suitcase
she has in little nightmares one after
breaking it constantly we finally break
her out of her distorted form and save
her our victory is short-lived as the
squirming of s chases the two of us to
the end of the game
at the end of the chase six holds out
her hand to save mono except she drops
him into the abyss while she escapes
mano wakes up with the only thing of
note being a chair in the middle of the
room
he then sits in the chair the lights
flash in and out as we see mano
transform into the thin man
the sequence seems to imply that mano
was trapped here for years and not just
a few seconds as we can see him age over
the course of the scene
as the camera pans out once more the
door closes to reveal the hallway we saw
in the beginning
this is the end of little nightmares 2.
so let's discuss that ending
there is a ton of possible theories
about this ending and what it means so
let me try to digest this in the most
easiest way possible the first question
is when is this game taking place
in multiple interviews the devs of the
game have stated that little nightmares
2
is a sequel but people are taking this
in two different ways
either this is a sequel meaning it's the
next little nightmares game to be
developed or it's a sequel meaning it
takes place after the events of little
nightmares 1. i'm currently subscribed
to the little nightmares 2 being a
prequel theory thanks to this secret
ending
if you collected all the glitch children
in the game you get a secret ending
cutscene after the credits in the secret
ending we see six escape through the tv
and beat her shadow version
the shadow version then motions over to
a poster showing the maw from little
nightmares
one afterwards the shadow version
disappears and she becomes hungry which
we all know too well thanks the previous
game
this is where the theories start to pull
on in most of the community and i
personally agree is that there is a time
loop present in the game's world this
would explain mano becoming the thin man
and why he chases us throughout the game
the thin man knows what's going to
happen at the end since he was already
betrayed by six so he's trying to stop
younger mono who we play as during the
game so the same thing doesn't happen to
him but that doesn't stop there as some
have argued that
six is also present in the loop herself
not just because of the betraying of
mono but because she's motioned to go to
the maw this ends with her becoming the
lady
and the owner of the mod thus repeating
an endless cycle of mono-saving
six betraying mono mono becomes the thin
man in hopes to stop future monos from
the same fate pulsex enters the maw and
kills the current lady of the ship where
she then becomes the owner of the ship
later in life the reasoning behind the
lady in six comparison is due to her
never-ending hunger we see her hunger
get worse and worse going from meat
to gnome to lady throughout the game she
needs things to satisfy her never-ending
hunger she was cursed with which could
explain the creation of the maw now
there are some holes left unfilled in
these theories like the fact that
according to the devs 6 and the lady
have no relation to one another which
completely undermines this theory but
regardless it is an interesting take on
the narrative
other community-wide theories speculate
that this game is the sequel of the last
game like it was advertised to be
as some have pointed out how six escape
she gets that hunger strike again
and it's possible that she was saving
mano from herself so that she didn't eat
him you could say that she could
possibly restrain herself from meeting
him but taking into account her actions
from the previous game she
really doesn't care who or what she eats
it's also possible that six discovered
that mono was the thin man all along and
that's why she dropped him
mono has been wearing the bag on his
head all game and the scene is the one
time where six can get a good look at
his face
thanks to her time in the dream world
where she came out distorted she may
have seen some things like the evolution
of the thin man and once she realized it
was mano she betrayed him
another likely idea is that the
squirming abyss we see at the end of the
game
is the one actually pulling the strings
the squirming abyss seems to be some
sort of higher intelligent being and
possibly even a more dangerous
antagonist
than the lady or the thin man regardless
if this game follows in little
nightmare's one's footsteps it should
release some future dlc that should at
least explain a couple of our questions
with that though we have just about run
out of time thank you all for joining me
today as we discuss little nightmares 2
and its possible future i highly
encourage all theories you have to be
written out in the comments we can get a
large group discussion going on the
topic
as always like the video if you enjoyed
it subscribe for more lore videos on
little nightmares 2
future games coming soon as well and
essay style analysis videos on your
favorite games
if you want a teaser to that style of
content i recommend clicking the video
coming up soon with that though take
care
and goodbye
[Music]
you